hello there I'm dr. Gregory Sadler and
this is the fifth in a series of videos
that I'm creating for what we might call
lifelong learners or self-directed study
participants people who want to study
philosophy largely on their own but
using the resources that are available
on the internet so people who aren't
doing academic study of philosophy in
the traditional university or college
setting but who have a desire or indeed
even a passion for the life of the mind
and this video is on somebody who I
think is really important kind of
undervalued by by many philosophers and
I actually would say unknown by many of
them as well but somebody who's a big
favorite of mine and I actually
sometimes say that I model my own work
after his and that is Marcus Tullius
Cicero the great Roman not just
philosopher but also order and lawyer
and statesman somebody who had a major
impact on history not just in terms of
what he did in the forum or in the civil
wars or those sorts of things but also
in the world of letters as we'll talk
about in just a little bit so this is
hopefully going to give you some helpful
advice about how you would begin to
study Cicero
one of the questions that I always want
to address early on in these videos is
very simple why should I study Cicero
why should I put in time that I could be
spending if not doing something other
than philosophy maybe on somebody who I
know is a big heavy hitter in philosophy
like David Hume or you know Rene
Descartes or you know Augustine of Hippo
or Thomas Aquinas or Aristotle people
that I I know I'm going to get a lot out
of and there's a lot of good answers to
that that I'm going to provide you here
one is that when you actually start
looking into Cicero you realize that he
is an important figure in the history of
philosophy and that's for several
reasons one of them has to do with the
fact that because of the project that he
had and because of the way that that
philosophy developed in the West
particularly during the Middle Ages but
also during during the Renaissance and
the modern period Cicero in effect
became one of the main sources that we
have for quite a few schools of ancient
philosophy so you know when it comes for
example to the epicurean school you know
we have Epicurus writings we've lost
most of those we have some phillyd a
massive stuff which is being translated
as we speak
we have Lucretius --is on the order of
things which by the way Cicero may have
edited and then we have Cicero's own
writings sister was not an epicurean and
he's actually kind of hostile to them at
many points but in on the ends book one
in on the nature of the gods book one in
other works as well he provides us with
a fairly decent sometimes systematic and
comprehensive understanding of what it
was that epicurean is actually thought
and taught and applied in there their
philosophy
same thing goes with with stoicism
there's a lot that we know about the
Stoics only because Cicero happens to
have written about it in his his works
like you know for example on duties
we've lost penaity is's tax pen a theist
was a middle stoic but we have Cicero's
text and Cicero may not be a stoic
himself but we learn a lot about
stoicism from him and similarly with the
academic skeptic school that we're gonna
talk about and there's even things about
Aristotle and the Peripatetic school
other you know lesser known figures and
and and movements within philosophy that
Cicero's works provide us with so that's
one reason that's that's particularly
important and it's good to keep in mind
that Cicero's works except for you know
his letters for the most part which were
rediscovered later in the Renaissance
they were preserved more or less we'll
talk about that in just a bit in the
Middle Ages in monasteries and then they
made their way into universities so
Cicero is one of the main sources
providing an understanding of ancient
philosophy that supplements that of the
Church Fathers like you know say
lactantius or clement of alexandria and
supplements all their pagan authors like
Plutarch who are quite important so this
is a it one important reason by itself I
think another reason why you should
think that Cicero is important is
because up until the 19th century the
early part of the 19th century everyone
else thought he was important you know I
mentioned David Hume earlier and there's
a good reason why I brought him up David
Hume cites Cicero constantly in his
works because Cicero was considered very
important more important than Aristotle
within that 18th century philosophical
milieu where Aristotle was actually
associated with sort of a moribund
scholasticism Cicero is was being
discussed all the time and providing you
full information about previous modes of
philosophy that people were interested
in and arguments that they were having
Hume may actually if you if you know
Cicero's works and then you look at
Humes works his dialogues on natural
religion uses a lot of the same sort of
structure as Cicero's on the nature of
the gods
and you can only see that if you
actually read the Cicero and you read
the he'll so there were many other
philosophers up until about the the end
of the 18th century who considered
Cicero to be very important to not just
the history of philosophy you know what
what was going on in the past but you
know as a model for how to understand
philosophy what what issues are
important and that changed in the 19th
century we'll talk about why that's the
case in just a bit another thing that I
think you know argues for why reading
Cicero is important is that he provides
you with a very nice model for how to do
philosophy in a comparative way and a
eclectic but also systematic way the
Cicero often is talked about as being
unoriginal and you know he's just sort
of regurgitating what other people put
out there that is not the case at all
all you have to do is read his works and
you see he's a very intelligent
interpreter of previous philosophical
thought he's adapting it to new
circumstances he's probing into
different systems and doctrines and
seeing what's really there coming up
with good arguments he's he's weaving
together a very interesting picture that
we can enter into and then explore on
our own and we have a lot of his works
so that's that's quite good and then the
last reason why I think you would wanna
read Cicero is he's enjoyable he's a
good writer a little bit of an acquired
taste we'll talk about that in just a
moment but he he really is worth you
know following along and seeing
he has to say he's taking the great
philosophies and placing them in
relation to each other and delving into
issues making distinctions where they
need to be made so if you like that sort
of thing you were going to like reading
Cicero so those are some good reasons
for delving into his corpus his body of
work
another question that people want me to
answer early on has to do with texts and
translations and additions so I have to
admit that quite frankly you know I
don't I don't like survey the whole
field of translations that's available
in part because I can read Latin and so
I'm very partial to these Loeb texts
I'm also used to reading more
old-fashioned less contemporary readable
translations so I don't really have too
much of an issue with that and these are
very nice to have so this is a Rackham
translation right Rackham you know
you're reading something kind of Oxford
II and and it may be a little bit out of
date for you but what's really cool
about these these Loeb editions is you
have the Latin on one side and the
English on the other so you know if you
can read the Latin or like you want to
start learning Latin although you don't
want to start with Cicero I'll tell you
about that in a moment you can compare
them back and forth and that that's
quite nice to be able to do so you know
these are some of my Loeb collection I
don't have all of his works but maybe
someday well now there's also some more
recent editions and translations that I
think I would like to call your
attention to
so Cambridge texts in the history of
philosophy and Cambridge texts in the
history of political thought has been
putting out these new translations of
Cicero's works so these are you know
quite nice usually quite affordable they
come with a good historical introduction
some notes on translation they come with
a sort of summary of that you can't get
all of Cicero's works in that form but
maybe down the line you will be able to
then there's you know they're heavily
footnoted as well which is quite nice so
I have you know on Duty's here and this
is a library edition of unmoral ends
which I'm currently working on with a
student of mine one other one that came
to my attention recently which I'll be
reviewing
in the coming months is in that new
series by Princeton University Press
this one is how to be a friend now it's
actually a translation of something that
we call the on friendship the day
yarmulke theá-- by cicero and again you
know comes with a little bit of an
introduction same thing here facing
pages you know Latin and English so
that's kind of nice to do that's not
gonna happen to all of Cicero's works
because the day I Maki Thea or the on
friendship is a rather short work
whereas tusculum disputations is quite
long you know on the ends is quite long
the academics on the nature of the guys
those are quite long so I don't think
you're gonna see them in those forms but
those are decent additions to get I will
say this that Cicero is because of his
style we actually talked about
Ciceronian style and sometimes really
use the word Ciceronian periods Latin
allows you to write in these massive
paragraph long sentences that convey all
these different shades of meaning and
connection because Latin is a different
kind of language than English is it's a
case language and Cicero took full
advantage of that I'm actually going to
tell you a little story here usually I
don't do too much of that in these but
you might get a kick out of this so when
I was learning Latin in a serious way
because I you know I had to actually
take Latin in sixth and seventh grade
but it was baby Latin you know it was
for sixth and seventh graders and then I
didn't really do anything with it until
later on
I actually didn't do anything with it an
undergraduate and it wasn't one of the
languages that I was studying in between
undergraduate and grad school but I did
I always like to you know collect army
field manuals and there was an Army
Field Manual that was written for Jag
officers these are the people who like
their the judicial branch of the army
and it was a teacher
of Latin book for officers and so I got
that and early on in my my graduate
studies I worked my way through the
whole thing and then I was like alright
now I actually know a lot of Latin let's
go to the library because I knew from
you know French and German that the next
thing to do was find some books and
start reading them and was like you know
I should read Cicero that would be kind
of fun and so I went and I got the
academics out of the library and I spent
an entire semester just working my way
through ten pages it was so difficult I
had to struggle so much and that was
because Cicero is difficult in Latin and
then I said oh man I really need to do
more work so I went and I bought myself
an Allen and green no grammar worked
through the entire thing and then
started reading easier authors like
Thomas Aquinas and Anselm of Canterbury
who's a little bit you know tougher and
then you know proceeded on eventually to
read Oh authors with the complexity of
style of Cicero and Augustine right
those are sort of like you know mastery
level texts but why am I telling you all
this well you know this structure to
Cicero's writing also sort of pervades
the English translations of his text so
you want to be attentive to that it is
complicated stylistically and and that's
because they're good translations if you
try to simplify Cicero you would
actually be deviating from from the text
another thing that I do want to bring up
about texts so we do have a lot of his
body of work but we don't have all of it
there are some that are either missing
like the pro trap caucus which we're
going to talk about in just a bit
or which are rather fragmentary another
example of that would be his dialogue on
fate which we'll also talk about in just
a bit but the you know on the laws and
on the republic and some of the other
works are also
fragmentary that means we don't have all
of the work and unless we're this is a
very common issue in ancient philosophy
unless we're extraordinarily lucky and
we discover a manuscript somewhere
preserved in you know jars or you know
because of an eruption or in some some
you know catacomb or something like that
we're probably stuck with what we've got
so you know that's that's probably
enough to say about the texts themselves
now the next question that we want to go
into is especially if you're a beginner
where do I start with some philosophers
it's really easy they may have written a
book like the introduction to my system
or here's how to get started you know
like if they were doing Conte we might
say well let's read the prologue omen at
any future metaphysics that might be the
spot to begin or if we're doing Plato we
might say well you know the ion or the
apology those are easy unfortunately we
don't have the one book that we probably
would want to start with and that is the
Hortensius the Hortensius a character
Hortensius in a dialogue is a pro
triptych a way to try to argue somebody
into studying philosophy talking about
why philosophy is very important and it
apparently was a fairly short work so
you know that would have been a great
one to start with we know of people
reading it like Augustine of Hippo who
said that it made him want to study
philosophy so it must've been pretty
good but we don't actually know much
about it unfortunately so that one we
have to put to the side so here's I
think there's a lot of different ways
one could get into Cicero I mean you
could jump into one of his big thick
books if you wanted to like you know the
Omni ends or the académica or you know
the tusculum disputations or you can
start with reading some of his speeches
but here's what I'm gonna say I think
that if you haven't read any Cicero up
to this point why not start with three
short works they give you kind of a good
representative idea of what his approach
is and what his project is like and so
those three works would be the on
friendship stoic paradoxes and on fate
now the on friendship is mostly
Aristotelian you know Cicero is actually
drawing on Aristotle's ideas in the
Nicomachean ethics books eight nine and
you're Demian ethic
like it's book book 7 where he's talking
about friendship and he's rethinking
this stuff and putting it into a Roman
context adding some new twists to it
like thinking about you know well when
should you actually break off a
friendship and when shouldn't you and
questions along those lines or how much
virtue does a virtuous friend have to
have so that's a nice accessible fairly
easy read I think it's pretty
straightforward there's a lot of
name-dropping but that that's ok you can
look those people up and then the stoic
paradoxes is also a short work it's also
good too and this goes for the on
friendship because Cicero tells you a
little bit about what his project is in
the introduction that he writes to these
works these stoic paradoxes is it begins
with with with Cicero complaining that
the Stoics have some really great ideas
but they don't use rhetoric at all
they don't use you know what we would
call effective communication to get
their points across and so he's gonna do
some of that so that that's a book
that's worth reading and then the on
fate now on fate is a a we could say
fragmentary text in that we don't have
the whole thing we do have a nice big
section and he is discussing this
question of fate and free will do we do
we actually have any free choice of our
own or is everything that we do going to
be faded in one way or another and he
examines a number of different positions
on this which include not just you know
schools you might have heard of like the
Stoics or the Epicureans or even the
academic skeptics but he also examines
de Doris's Megerian position on it he
brings up a few other people he talks
about an argument called the lazy
argument that's well worth looking into
and so I think if you put those three
texts together
that's a nice starting place for Cicero
and then you got to think about well
what do I really want to get into I mean
ideally you'd read all of his his
philosophical works I think that's a
great thing
do but you might be attracted to Cicero
because you know that he deals with
something that you're particularly keen
to study so if it's epicureanism you
probably want to look at on the ends and
on the nature of the gods and the
académica academics right and that's
probably you know where you're gonna
find the most interesting stuff that's
being discussed there on fate of course
talks about Epicurus - if you're
interested in stoicism there's a wider
range of of texts that you would look at
so those texts that I mentioned already
and then you would look at the on duties
you would look at the tusculum
disputations you would also look at his
book on divination because it deals with
the Stoics conception of you know
determinism and whether there is any
freedom or possibility of doing things
differently you might also be interested
in Cicero for the sake of studying
rhetoric or the relations between
rhetoric and philosophy and he's got
quite a few books you know like on the
order
you know the topics you know a number of
other works that you would you would
delve into and there you're gonna find
out that Cicero is also in many respects
kind of Aristotelian he thinks of
rhetoric as something that a philosopher
ought to have not in the way that the
rhetoric teachers did where it's all
sort of formal exercises and how to push
people's buttons
he's very similar to Aristotle in that
he thinks that you know rhetoric by
itself is a dangerous tool this is what
Plato picked up on as well but here's
where Aristotle and Cicero differ from
Plato it's also a necessary tool because
you have to compete against other
philosophers and ordinary people and
their ideas so you need to be able to
persuade and you need to be able to
organize your materials well so you
might look at his rhetorical treatises
as well you know you might also depend
on what your particular
interested in if you're really
interested in issues about the emotions
tusculum disputations books 3 and 4 if
you're really really interested in the
question of you know knowledge the
académica is is about that sort of thing
so it kind of depends on where your your
bent is but the good thing is you know
if you gave it some time you could
probably read your way through all the
philosophical treatises you know in a
fairly short amount of time and when I
say short amount of time I mean like
over the course of a couple weeks if
you're really spending a lot of time on
it or a couple months if it's if it's
more periodic that you're you're doing
it so that's I think that's some some
useful advice about where to start and
how to do things I do want to say one
other thing about the how to start so
when you're approaching Cicero it's
important to keep in mind who this guy
is and where he's coming from in
philosophy he is somebody who had the
advantage of being able to study with a
lot of really important representatives
of the philosophical schools so he got
to study with you know the hardcore
Epicureans the hardcore academics
skeptics the hardcore Stoics the
hardcore Aristotelian peripatetic right
so he got a really good education and he
also had access to books he was a rich
guy not not from a you know absolutely
upper class family by Roman standards
but you know fairly high up there and he
was able to get his hands on books and
studied them he had the opportunity to
do that he had leisure in which to do
that so you're gonna be jumping into
somebody who is not like beginning at a
beginner level alright he's not saying
you know let me explain Aristotle for
the average Joe on the street no as he's
not doing that so you know he's expect
to jump in at
kind of a fast pace the other thing that
that's important to think about is that
he is within a set of traditions and he
assumes that the reader is going to be
somewhat conversant with them and that
may not always be the case that that's
why sometimes having all those those
footnotes and introductions can be
really useful for you or hopefully in
all the videos that I provide are useful
for you as well so that's information
about how to get yourself started
I think that in order to get the most
out of reading Cicero early on you
probably need to know something about
what his overall project was and why he
was doing that that'll tell you a bit
about why he's writing things in the way
he is and making the arguments he is now
you'll get this out of the introductions
to his various books when you put them
all together but it might be helpful to
have that you know before you actually
jump in so one of the key things that
Cicero wanted to do what was a
linguistic project a project of
translation Cicero was bothered by the
fact that you had all of these elitist
Romans sort of like people who do this
today with French or German and and they
were like you know you can't study you
know you can't study philosophy in any
language other than Greek so we're gonna
when we talk about philosophy we'll only
do it in Greek we're not going to do it
with that slumming language Latin and
Cicero's like now the Latin language is
pretty good you know we may not have
actually come up with all these ideas
but I think we can express it in Latin
and I'm gonna show all of you that that
can be done so that was that was one of
his main projects he's translating Greek
philosophy into Latin but he's not
translating it word for word he's doing
a different kind of translation a
different that's a Latin word by the way
translate see oh he's carrying something
from one place to another and he's he's
setting up his works to be for a Latin
audience every once in a while he'll
mention a Greek word in it but he'll
always tell you here's a Latin
equivalent for that word here's a way to
express that word so that that's a
really I think important key part of his
project he wants to write these books so
that literate Romans people throughout
the empire
well not the Empire at that time
throughout the Republic at that time
it's going to be become an empire
fairly quickly during his lifetime
towards the end of it so that they can
actually enjoy and get the benefit of
Greek philosophy so that's one key issue
he also is engaged in what we can call
an encyclopedia project he's not writing
an encyclopedia like we think of where
there's like entries for each word like
Marcus Tullius Cicero Roman statesman
and orator blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah right he's not doing that instead
he's writing books that are supposed to
cover each major area and topic in
philosophy so he's trying to produce an
encyclopedia of philosophy one body of
work that will give you all of the stuff
that you need to know when you need to
know it so you know you want to know
about your duties read on duties and
maybe on the ends and also you know
Tusculum disputations and also this book
in that book right you want to know how
to speak well on the order or the brutus
or you know the topics you need to have
copia right that's what the topics are
for you want to know a little bit about
epicureanism and the academics
criticisms of the Epicureans notions of
innate ideas well there you go it's in
the academics and so you know that's
part of what he's doing so when you're
reading a work of his you're actually
reading a part of a larger body of work
that's supposed to be if not necessarily
systematic in the sense that it's
providing one coherent system at least
comprehensive there's often a lot of
points where you're like man I wish that
sister ought to talk more about this guy
you know like for example I I wish he'd
talk more about Aristo who was a sort of
sort of stoic and hero Nemus who is a
sort of Aristotelian because we've lost
their works but you know Cicero I think
he kind of assumed that that people
would have access to the works so he's
providing us with as much information as
he thinks is necessary another
thing to realize about his project is
that for Cicero philosophy was indeed a
way of life and this is an important
idea in ancient times it runs throughout
medieval times except for maybe some of
the scholastic philosophy but even a lot
of that is actually connected with
living philosophy and it continues on in
in in the modern period to some degree
it disappears with modern academic
philosophy which is rather abstract and
and you know uprooted from life contexts
for Cicero as for the Stoics as for the
the skeptics as for the Epicureans as
further their later rivals in Jewish and
and Christian philosophy as for the
plate nests and the neoplatonist and
middle plate inist and even for the
Aristotelian philosophy was something
that you would live it was supposed to
affect the way that you live it was
supposed to give you tools that you
could use to understand things it was
supposed to help you work on your
emotions it was supposed to help you
analyze what was going wrong with things
and how you might make them better so
that's a motive in a lot of his works
he's not just writing it to write a
treatise on this or that it's supposed
to be something that could in some way
be applicable the last thing I want to
say about his project that I I don't
think you need to necessarily take into
account you know to help you understand
the writings but I think is good
background knowledge is Cicero was a
busy guy he was involved in Roman
politics he went through what was called
the cursus honorum these offices that
you would do he took part in rulership
he was actually offered a place in the
triumvirate that scizor that Ivan Caesar
Pompey and Crassus formed it would have
been a quadroon Verret right it would
have been a four four person rule and he
turned them down but why did they offer
to him because he was so important and
so influential and so
into politics he took part in the civil
war between Pompey and Caesar picked the
Pompey side reluctantly sort of like
Cato did as well and they lost and you
know eventually Cicero would get killed
by partisans of Mark Antony his son
managed to escape fortunately Cicero did
a lot of his writing not not the
political writings you know the the
speeches those are obviously written for
political purposes and not the letters
but he did a lot of his philosophical
writings in what we can call his down
time down time in two different ways so
when he was not as involved in political
matters because he was out of power or
couldn't do anything then he used some
of that time to write philosophy it's
also down time in another way that might
make you feel down Cicero had a daughter
who he loved very much and appears to
have been his you know in many respects
intellectual and practical equal her
name was Thalia and she was very
involved in his life as a matter of fact
he divorced his second wife and part cuz
she couldn't get along with Thalia and
unfortunately till he had died she died
before her father and Cicero felt an
incredible amount of grief over this and
so what did he do he turned his his
grief into an opportunity to attain some
sort of consolation by spending his time
thinking about and writing about
philosophy so it was down time in
another sense and that that's kind of
important to take into account I think
so hopefully that helps you
contextualize what this guy is up to and
so when you go to his works keep all of
that in mind and and I think that will
help you frame things there is one other
thing that I do need to tell you about
that
and I'm gonna talk more about that in
the next section but here it is
Cicero identifies with a particular
school of philosophy the school that he
identifies with is the academic skeptic
school academic in that it's in Plato's
Academy Plato's Academy starts out with
Plato of course and Aristotle studying
there and so specific light oh dies he's
Plato's nephew and then there's you know
a few others who are more or less
faithful to Plato's project and then the
Academy gets taken over by these these
other people like our killer cuts allows
right and they're skeptics they you know
there was skepticism before that you
know there's pyro but within the academy
they start saying well you know Socrates
is this guy who says you know I know
that I don't know let's actually focus
on knowledge and think about what we
actually do know and what we don't know
and there's different kinds of
skepticism there's like a hardcore man
we don't know anything
doubt everything kind of skepticism and
then there's a more moderate you know
carny a days sort of style of skepticism
or the like you know I think we can at
least have probabilities we can't say
anything for sure but we can say this is
likely I'm willing to revise my my
arguments later Cicero belongs to that
and part of the reason why Cicero writes
dialogues and writes dialogues in which
different philosophical schools are
engaging with each other and then you've
also got Cicero sometimes as a character
pointing out flaws in the different
arguments is because that's what
academic skepticism looks like for him
it's not a I doubt everything I don't
know nobody could know anything it's not
any of that sort of stuff it's skeptic
you know the skeptics were the skeptic
coy seekers on a path Cicero wants
knowledge he just wants to actually like
see what everyone else has to say about
it and provide their best arguments
and then see whether they're any good
that's part of his project and I think
he's doing that not just for us readers
but also for himself to some degree
I think there's a few things that I can
say about the format of Cicero's text
that may prove useful for you as you're
beginning to study Cicero and the first
thing I have for you is a little bit of
advice do not skip over the introductory
material to jump right into the heart of
it because Cicero and the introductory
part is telling you why he wrote the
book and what sort of you know you know
take he's going to have on things and
it's he's also talking about the larger
project you know I meant that I was just
talking about earlier that he's involved
in those are really important points
early on and sometimes they'll show up
and you know introductions to different
books in larger works books are sort of
like chapters right the each one was a
scroll so don't skip that another thing
I need to point out is the the works
that are fragmentary or incomplete
they're the best copies we have you know
the scholars have put together as much
as we can reconstruct of Cicero's texts
that's what we've got to work with so
you know don't feel dismayed or anything
because you don't have the full Cicero's
Republic we have a good bit of it and
and that's that's enough right so that's
a format thing as well now I want to
talk about I'd mentioned that a lot of
his works or dialogues there are a few
that are not dialogues but most of them
are the Philips off course obviously as
letters or letters and the speeches or
speech that's great
those aren't dialogues dialogues come in
a lot of different formats right if you
think about a platonic dialogue or a
dialogue by Xenophon if you've read him
they're a bit different than Ciceronian
dialogues in Ciceronian dialogues you've
got like a starting point and then
somebody will say you know I've been
thinking about this this issue or you
know the you know I wonder what you
Epicureans think or you Stoics think and
then usually there's some some guy there
to say well I'll tell you all about it
right and then they do four-page
to page after page and sort of
systematic exposition and then after
that there'll be somebody else who will
come in and say you know I don't think I
buy this part and here's why and then
there might be some back and forth
between them but it's not a dialogue
like a Shakespeare play or any other
kind of play that you're used to where
it's back and forth all the time it's
more like here's a presentation then
then we got some you know chitchat and
then some you know more presentation
back and forth like that
and and so you might find that
stylistically a little bit you know
boring bought think of it this way
Cicero is doing his best to try to
convey to us through these characters
what it is that the different schools
had to offer and how they thought of
things there's not a lot of you know you
could call it dramatic voice within the
dialogue I mean there is sometimes a
little bit of joking around and ribbing
each other right or saying hey you're
your ancestors did this and then you got
to go look up who that person was but
it's not like Plato's dialogues were
through Symmachus comes in like a lion
Socrates you snivelling you know person
you should wipe your nose and pay me for
teaching you but there's nobody like
that really in Cicero's dialogues but
there is a lot of discussion however of
interesting characters both in Greek and
Roman settings and sometimes in other
settings as well another thing to
remember as an academic skeptic Cicero
feels himself entitled to be eclectic so
that means that he can if he thinks that
the Stoics have something right he can
take that from the Stoics and use it if
he's got if there's something else that
he thinks the Aristotelian czar
completely correct about like for
example the importance of rhetoric man
he's gonna take that on and he's gonna
have his characters or himself as one of
the characters tell you all about it so
that that's an important part of his
dialogue format to keep in mind he
doesn't always show his hand
in every single case so that's you know
also worth worth considering too but you
don't always have to worry about what is
Cicero's own point of view you can
appreciate the the dialogues or the
treaty sees if you want to call them
that as sort of you know living well
thought-out well arranged expositions of
a variety of different systemic
philosophical viewpoints so that's
probably enough about for men
if you're participating in the sort of
wider world of philosophy particularly
if you're not doing in an academic
setting but this also applies to that
but you're doing it in a the you know
sort of popular setting which includes a
lot of online discussions you are gonna
see a lot of people saying things about
Cicero that might make you feel a little
bit concerned about whether you're
getting things right or whether you're
even wasting your time on somebody and
the two biggest things I would say have
to do with whether he's original and
therefore important and whether he
belongs to this school or that school so
let's talk about the first the the
second one first right
particularly since there's a lot of
online forums devoted to Stoics and
stoicism and there's a lot of people
involved in them will have a very low
level of understanding at this point in
time which I'm not complaining about you
know that's what forums are for you know
like Facebook groups and things like
that
people will bring up Cicero and they
will say well you should study Cicero
because he's a stoic he's not a stoic he
does in fact take a lot from stoicism
and he does argue for stoicism and works
like the stoic paradoxes right but
Cicero is not a stoic he is an eclectic
who takes on a lot of elements of
stoicism into his moral theory where he
thinks the Stoics have things right he
also takes a lot from Aristotle and in
fact he makes the argument at certain
points and some people think that he's
completely you know serious about this
others think maybe he's just sort of
trying out ideas that the Stoics and the
Aristotelian czar actually doing the
same thing just calling things by
different names that's that's another
issue that we could go into but he is
neither an Aristotelian nor a stoic
formally speaking he is an academic
skeptic or and just call him an academic
because he tells us he belongs to that
school in practice however that means
that he is
and eclectic now an eclectic could be a
sort of smorgasbord kind of person where
I just pick a little bit of this a
little bit of this and kind of put them
all together into some sort of composite
mess and I mean mess rather than mass
hay or an eclectic could be somebody
who's much more careful or like you know
I like that over there that seems to
work I like this over here let's see if
we can put these together oh it's kind
of tough to make them fit we got to grow
this here and add a bit here and maybe
shave a little bit of this off here ah
now they're coming together that's the
kind of eclectic that Cicero is and he
can do so thinking that that's what it
means for him to be an academic he is
not an academic skeptic as I've
mentioned thinking that we can't know
anything and Socrates was great because
he he says he doesn't you know he knows
what he doesn't know that is not the
kind of academic that Cicero is Cicero
thinks we can know things and he thinks
that we ought to know things and we just
have to get them from multiple sources
so that's one problem we can kind of put
aside don't get worried when people
start telling you who Cicero was and
what kind of philosophical position he
had because most of the people out there
saying that sort of thing in the popular
philosophy sphere don't know what
they're talking about the other issue is
one that actually comes up a little bit
more from academic philosophy both the
academic philosophy of the present and
that going back to the 19th century as I
mentioned Cicero was very widely read
and highly respected throughout the
history of philosophy into the 18th
century in the nineteenth century it's
not just Cicero
but Hellenistic philosophy in general
tends to get dismissed that includes the
Epicureans that includes the Stoics that
includes the middle platanus that
includes the sceptics there there you
know the idea that the Greek city-state
declining you know meant that that Plato
and Aristotle their grand vision had
this sort of an endpoint and now we're
in that degenerate Alexandria and
Hellenistic philosophy which is really
no good
that was a prevalent conception you see
Hegel saying stuff like that you see
other people you know saying like you
know Windell bond for a vinda bond
rather you know popular historian of
philosophy writing in German who
influenced a lot of Americans you see
people like Heidegger saying ridiculous
things in the 20th century like really
you can only you know do philosophy in a
philosophical language and those would
be Greek and German not Latin
there's a lot of that sort of stuff out
there and it's still floating around and
a lot of people in academia were taught
that sort of thing in a little bit of
history philosophy that they got but
that's that's weak kind of bunk it's not
really based in a thorough study of the
texts from a viewpoint that didn't
already have these blinders on about the
the unimportance of Hellenistic
philosophy it's becoming recognized more
and more just how important Cicero is
and that's good and the same thing is
happening with the Stoics and the
Epicureans and the skeptics and middle
plate and that's not just neoplatonist
like Latinas but middle plaintiffs like
Plutarch so Cicero's star is is rising
again there was you know another
criticism that was made along those
lines
well he's not original you know he's
just taking ideas of other people and
repackaging them in a Roman culture and
latin language garb and you know i think
to some degree that's true but cicero
didn't aim to be original and as a
matter of fact most philosophers
throughout that time weren't aiming to
be original either
that's a weird romantic you know late
modern notion that a lot of people have
that you don't need to buy into you know
you don't need so as a matter of fact
it's good that Cicero is faithfully
representing to us what the Epicureans
thought we don't want him being all that
original when he's presenting them we
want them to stick to topic and tell us
just what the hell these people said
right do the original stuff later on on
your own
time so that's not something that I
think you have to worry about as a
matter of fact the the you know what
people are perceiving as his weakness is
really a strength of his philosophical
work so that's probably enough about
that
what are my last thoughts about Cicero
and you engaging in self-directed study
of him well I think if you wanna know
ancient philosophy or if you want a good
grounding that's gonna help you with
medieval and early modern philosophy
definitely somebody you got to read and
I think that you're gonna find him to be
a surprisingly helpful and interesting
source of ideas and information and
you'll also start to appreciate him as a
writer and thinker in his own respect so
you know it it's a bit more challenging
than some of the other philosophers you
might read reading Cicero but it's well
worth your time and if you're going to
do it let me you know congratulate you
on picking some some great project for
yourself that's gonna fill in a lot of
gaps if you're not yet convinced then
maybe watch the video again and maybe
I'll convince you or you know read read
those three books that I mentioned or
you know in the the part about how to
start read the on friendship and on fate
and stoic paradoxes and see what you
think see whether he's worth going into
or not I think you'll be convinced that
Cicero is well worth studying he's one
of my favorite philosophers I'm very
happy to give you a little bit of advice
that I hope will be will be helpful for
you as you carry on your own
self-directed study of Cicero and that's
pretty much all that I've got
you